ANATOLY PULYAEVSKIY: Right.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Anatoly.
And just a fun fact--
I just double-checked the
list of all the talks in this
conference, and it looks like
this one is the only one that
has "server-side" in the title.
[APPLAUSE]
Just a precious five
minutes for server-side.
So this is about
server-side Dart on NodeJS,
or how people in
Portland like to say it,
putting a bird on it.
[LAUGHTER]
So first of all, why NodeJS?
Why not Dart VM?
And as much as I like
Dart VM, the only place
I can be sure it's always
installed on is on my laptop.
That's not really anywhere yet.
And on the contrary,
with NodeJS,
you can actually see it
very much everywhere.
For instance, in Firebase,
there is a good chance
that some of you are going
to build a Flutter or web
app that uses Firebase.
And in Firebase, they
have this service
called Firebase Functions.
Have any one of you used it?
All right, quite a few.
So this is basically a
way to run your JavaScript
in the cloud in a
JavaScript function.
So why not try this
function in Dart,
and compile it in JavaScript,
and run it in the cloud?
Some other interesting
reasons would be code sharing,
as was mentioned
many times before me,
and cohering a
development environment.
So what it means how to build
a Dart application for NodeJS?
So it's basically very much,
how would you build it for web?
It's basically, you
need some Dart code.
Then you just add
some more Dart code
in the form of JS bindings.
And then you just
compile it with Dart2js
and get a JavaScript file.
And the only one
missing bit here
is you just need a special
header, node_preamble.
This is not my
creation, by the way.
This package has been
around for a while.
You just prepend
a special snippet
in front of this JS file,
and it just works in Node.
So what's possible?
I have two demos today.
One is the Firebase
Cloud Functions.
And I just need to switch
to my code editor here.
So this is an example HTTP
Firebase cloud function.
Can you see this
code, by the way?
Whoops.
Is it better?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANATOLY PULYAEVSKIY:
OK, so I have a date
function here, which is
an HTTP function that
accepts incoming HTTP requests
and replies with some response
to it.
And the way you register it is
by using this built-in Firebase
functions object.
You set a key on it
with your function.
Now, what you can
notice here is basically
there is not much
about Node here.
That's my preference.
I don't like having require
calls in my Dart code.
It's more like idiomatic Dart.
And it actually works.
I'm not going to go
through the deploy process
here because it takes a while.
But I have this link here.
This is this same function
deployed to the cloud.
It might take a while
first time to load.
But this is it.
And I'm refreshing it, and
it just shows me the date.
I mean, this is an intentionally
very basic example.
You can do quite a
bit more than that.
You can store that data
in real-time database,
in Fire Store, send push
notifications, whatever
Firebase services
you want to use.
The other example is
not about Firebase.
It's just I wanted
to try and explore
what else can we do with
this combination with Dart
and NodeJS.
And here's an example
script I have here.
This is a very basic HTTP server
which is powered by Dart VM.
Right?
We bind to a host and port,
and we listen for requests,
and we just return some--
write some responses.
And actually, here, I'm
using the HTTP package
to call this same date function
in the cloud that I showed you.
And it brings out the result.
So I can actually run this code.
And it shows me--
this is Dart VM.
No surprises here.
But what if we can do
this, something like this?
We can just replace
Dart with Node here?
Obviously, we
cannot do this here,
but I can try and do it
a little bit differently.
I just want to replace Dart
VM I/O with Node I/O. And here
it would be the same--
like this.
Now we just need to
compile it with Pub.
This is basically the
same Dart2js compilation.
All right, so now
I'm using Node to run
the same application that was
using the Dart I/O before.
And as you see, it works.
It basically uses
the same interfaces.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
So we can really get
a very Darty feel
when working with NodeJS.
That's what I
wanted to show you.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]